hi I'm amber J and we're here at
BuzzFeed motion pictures where people
come from across the country and even
around the world to work and they all
got their start somewhere so I'm going
to go around the office and ask what was
your first job my first job my very
first job my first job was working at
the gap no one no one laughed okay good
I feel good I opened my own lemonade
stand when I was 12 and I hired my
brother and my neighbors to work for me
my parents were like you're gonna get a
job at 14 it was like a bookshop in cafe
15 I got a job doing that just making
pizza bagels and lattes sixteen and I
worked at McDonald's I was a cashier at
a Chinese restaurant I worked for nuns
and I did their marketing Bath and Body
Works camp counselor I sold knives for
cut cut a summer internship at a tech
company I was a host at Joe's Crab Shack
so I answered the phone
I took people to the tables and I
cleaned up the bathroom of a crab ship
you have to like pick up all the popcorn
you have to sweep everything up shitty
job assistant pet groomer being a PA on
set I had to pick up dog poop for a good
couple weeks before I got paid the
acting as an extra on a movie it was at
a Korean entertainment company a start
as an intern there I made a lot of
coffee
I was making sandwiches and now I can
make a really good sandwich not just
because I'm a woman I used to answer the
phone like this welcome to a a hard
where will we put the word hard in
hardware
no my boss is like it out my philosophy
in life is just take each day one step
at a time and just don't worry about the
future you should be able to find some
amount of happiness and what you're
doing don't think something's out of
reach are unattainable you're pursuing
an artistic career
I think jobs are for quitting and your
career is your art you never know what
opportunity leads to your next one
so it might seem like a shitty job but
doing that shitty job might help you
meet a really cool person it helps you
get a better job
okay this paper whatever you do you do
your best don't half-ass anything that's
what I would say if your clean toilets
you won't be the best toilet cleaner
ever